Щоденно у новинах повідомляють про жахливі аварії на українських дорогах.
Щороку понад 3000 українців гинуть у ДТП.
Україна - у п'ятірці антилідерів за кількістю смертельних аварій у Європі.
У чому  причини такої невтішної статистики?
В Україні більше половини ДТП стаються через перевищення швидкості.
Експерти вважають, держава недостатньо використовує засоби контролю швидкості на дорогах.
Наприклад, система фото- і відеофіксації запрацювала лише у 2020 році.
До того ж, кількість цих приладів на дорогах все ще недостатня.
Сутність камер така - їх треба встановлювати там, де відбувається найбільше ДТП
і там, де водій дуже швидко їде, де вся дорога сприяє тому, щоб водії дуже швидко їхали.
Окрім недостатнього контролю швидкості, в Україні також існує проблема з трактовкою ПДР.
Так, приміром, у містах допустима швидкість 50 км/год, однак водії мають безкарний ліміт у 20 кілометрів.
Це означає, що водій, який пересувається містом зі швидкістю 69 кілометрів на годину, взагалі не буде притягнутий до відповідальності.
А якщо водій їхатиме містом зі швидкістю 99 кілометрів, його штраф складатиме лише 340 гривень.
Водій буде дуже швидко їхати в місті, і перевищуючи на 49 кілометрів, він усе одно отримає лише 340 гривень штрафу.
Це дуже незначний штраф на відміну від наслідків, до яких призводить надмірна швидкість.
За даними громадської організації "Безпечні дороги", у 2020 році ременями безпеки в обласних центрах пристібалися тільки 26 відсотків водіїв,
тобто лише кожен четвертий.
З одного боку, це частково пояснюють маленькими штрафами, які діяли донедавна - 51 гривня.
Тільки у лютому 2021 року штраф за нехтування пасками безпеки підвищили до 510 гривень.
Коли держава встановлює такі смішні штрафи за порушення правил, то сама наче демонструє, що пасками можна нехтувати, нарікають експерти.
Інша причина - це свого роду культура ігнорування пАсків безпеки, яка панує серед українських водіїв, які скаржаться, що ремені - це незручно.
А також вважають, що для пасажирів на задньому сидінні немає потреби пристібатися.
Поширений також міф, що паски безпеки не потрібні, оскільки в машині є подушки безпеки.
Або що при зіткненні безпечніше вилетіти з машини через лобове скло, ніж бути пристебнутим під час ДТП.
Наприклад, якби у нас була така ситуація в Україні, що всі водії мали б звичку пристібатися,
то приблизно до 900 життів можна було б врятувати щороку.
Українські водії також свідомо відволікаються на смартфони та інші гаджети під час водіння.
Активісти кампанії "За безпечні дороги" провели всеукраїнське дослідження і виявили,
що кожен п’ятий водій користується телефоном під час управління автомобілем.
Така поведінка учетверо збільшує ризик ДТП, а читання чи писання повідомлень за кермом збільшує вірогідність аварії у 20 разів.
Недолуге планування доріг також сприяє високій смертності у ДТП.
Існує жарт, що чим більш розбита дорога в Україні, тим менша на ній вірогідність дорожньо-транспортної пригоди,
оскільки на такій трасі водії не набиратимуть швидкість.
Однак насправді справа не стільки у якості доріг, скільки в ігноруванні владою урбаністичних рішень, які унеможливили б перевищення швидкості.
Наприклад, встановлення кільцевих перехресть малого радіусу, острівців безпеки, а також звуження проїжджих смуг у населених пунктах.
Інфраструктура впливає на безпеку дорожнього руху. І в Києві, і в Україні вона дуже часто проєктувалася з урахування інтересів автомобілістів.
Тобто ми можемо зустрічати, що в Києві є багато смуг, які спроектовані так, що водій буде дуже швидко їхати.
Натомість багато заміських доріг в Україні мають лише дві смуги, на яких ДТП часто стаються саме під час небезпечних обгонів по зустрічній смузі.
Активісти також стверджують, що органи влади не моніторять і не аналізують ДТП, що вже сталися.
Такий аналіз міг би допомогти унеможливити аварії у майбутньому на одних і тих же ділянках.
Тому іноді самі кияни беруться за аналіз місць частих аварій.
Ось на прикладі цієї вулиці, яка здається займає восьме місце з кількості загиблих ДТП і травмованих (у Києві).
Тут досить швидкісна траса проходить, тому що це траса і великий автомобільний трафік,
вона проходить між двома житловими районами, фактично, розрізаючи їх навпіл.
Єдині дві точки, де ви можете перейти ці вулиці по землі, якщо ви мама з візочком або старенька бабуся, якій по східцям ходити важко,
або просто ви молодий не дуже тверезий парубок, який бачить мету і не бачить перешкод,
то таких місць, де можна перейти вулицю по землі, їх всього лише два.
Після того як Сергій проаналізував десятки місць підвищеної аварійності у Києві, на деяких з них поставили камери фото- і відеофіксації.
Але багато ділянок так і залишаються небезпечними локаціями з високим ризиком аварійних ситуацій.
Утім, зауважують експерти, для того, щоб знизити рівень смертності на дорогах,
необхідно не тільки змінювати штрафи і правила, а також свідомість українських водіїв,
для яких порушення правил дорожнього руху стало нормою.